everyone so I just wanted to welcome you
to this interactive adventure in Hawaii
now my sister and I recently took a trip
there and we did a lot of crazy things
what you're about to see is a quick
montage of all the things that we did
there and directly after that you'll be
presented with a menu that will let you
choose which adventure you like to see
first now if at any point in this video
or any of the adventure videos you wish
to choose a new adventure just click
this annotation right there and it will
take you back to the menu I hope you
guys enjoy and be sure to let me know
what your favorite adventure was that we
did
all right so which adventure are you
gonna choose first
Oh
you